hey I'm back and I have another quick
tip for you if you have any problems on
digestion and you're doing ki Dell and
let's say you're doing two meals a day
and let's just say for example your
first meal is at 12:00 and your next one
is at 4:00 okay I recommend and just try
this out to see if it can help you
consume only protein and fat for one
meal and do your vegetables or salad for
the next meal okay I find that that
seems to work for a lot of people
because when you combine everything
together it just seems to be a bit hard
for your system to take on and some
people do very well with this so go
ahead and try and it might help you now
if you're doing one meal a day what I
recommend is do your protein and then
wait maybe I don't know an hour and then
have your salad but not all at the same
time it's just something to try and it
may help you alright
thanks for watching so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notifications daily notifications that
sounds weird well I'll just remind you
on a daily basis how about that